people think that we're Father and Son
you got you look just like your father
then I'll just lip lock him right in
front of them can you imagine marrying
someone 37 years older than you if
you're truly in love does age really
matter I'm katak Kashi and in today's
episode of Split Decision we're focusing
on age Gap couples the goal of split
decision is to have meaningful
conversations with the people that
matter most don't be afraid to tell your
partner how you really feel the first
prompt is my partner is the best I've
ever had in bed make your split
decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 all right go ahead and turn
around wow look at
this very sexually happy right now okay
Cheryl you are dancing for joy why don't
you go ahead and start I keep
happy sex is great with him I was his
first which I didn't know wow until
later on was he good on the first time
yes and I would have never known she
should have known cuz when I first met
her we were in the bathroom and I forgot
what happened I'm going tell it but um I
pre- ejaculated over her legs like you
know I was just like rubbing against her
and I just ejaculated all over and I was
just like she should know was virgin
then but it didn't click so when she
actually spent a night and it was
amazing night I ain't never done nothing
like that I picked her up all typ of
stuff it was just going with the flow
and it just got magical you know okay
wow Jeff he's uh Trey's the best you've
ever been with huh tre's yeah absolutely
uh and that's saying something cuz I'm a
gay man and you know that's lived
through the ' 80s 90s and the 2000s so
that's a lot of guys so yeah
okay we met in my dorm room and I wanted
him you know the first thing in my mind
was sex and it's more passionate for me
and he was the only person that really
brought that energy that I like to bring
whether it's kissing it's holding it's
just everything it's you know matching
Talia I have had great other sexual
experiences and I wouldn't have gotten
married as young as I did if I hadn't
like had a life before that but the
connection that we have was unmatched it
doesn't matter if we go through like ups
and downs it brings us back together
beautiful Brian well John is the best
huh I'll tell you we've been together
like going on six years and still even
when he just like gets out of the shower
and like walks by I'm like damn and I'm
like this is so nice to feel this way
still you know but he's definitely
opened me up in more ways than one
sexually you know which is always always
nice hi my name is John and I'm 29 years
old and I'm Brian I'm 63 and you're
going to make me do math yeah 33 years
34 if you're looking at it depending on
when the birthdays happen the calendar
the next prompt is my partner and I have
special sexual fantasies and
Kinks make your split decision in 3 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around Quan you say yes Cheryl says no
what is it I mean I say yes cuz I do
like some kinky stuff I want to be a
slave I ain't going to flex I have a
fantasy for that I'm sorry for the
people my people I'm sorry I'm just
saying that now it's not in the same way
but this just like you ever had like
little mental thing where you like oh
M's wife home alone I've be saying that
to all the time she like shut up no why
do you say no I don't really have a
fantasy like that but if it happens and
we're doing it then hell yeah John well
I think just the age thing plays into my
fantasy in that you're like the daddy
for me you're and sometimes I've called
you coach and I played Sports my whole
life and actually one of the ways I knew
that I was gay was I was really
attracted to my soccer coach and so
Brian how's it going
coach Trey well very similar to everyone
else I'm the daddy but we're also into
leather so I'm the sir in our
relationship he's my baby boy and I have
no idea what he's talking
about what what's your like favorite
thing that you love to do together
fisting piss play some of the other
stuff that we've done um public sex
clubs like we really like we do like
being watched like personally public you
know we've done it in Parks we've done
it everywhere in airports um piss play
can you tell me a little bit more about
that well it's not what it sounds
like it's totally what it sounds like
but how did that H you guys like had a
conversation like hey are you into the
whole pissing thing or a little bit but
it like do in truthfully honest it
happened inside my dorm those was like
like the fifth or sixth time we up and I
just stopped and in the middle of it he
was like confused why I stopped and I
just you know let let the it wasn't
because it wasn't because of the the
piss that was bothering me I'm like but
what what about the floor you know I was
I was more concerned about who's going
to clean the up my name is Jeff Blaine
I'm 58 my our age Gap is 36 years I'm
Trey harston and I'm 22 so yeah 36 36
years what you doing oh hey just working
on this self love project but
something's just off I mean look at this
heart well you know there isn't just one
way to love yourself self love looks
different for everybody and that heart
might be perfect for you I mean maybe
that's true but how can I know for sure
you could start by checking out Lilo and
the timing is perfect because they have
some impressive Black Friday deals to
help you explore what self love means
for you use promo code Jubilee 5 for an
additional 5% off your next lethal
purchase even on discounted items how I
already feel relieved thanks so much to
Lilo for sponsoring this video you have
my whole
heart this
heart I'm worried my partner might leave
me for someone their own age make your
split decisions in 3 2
1 okay go ahead and turn
around y'all are confident love okay
well have you all ever fantasized about
your partner being your own age
absolutely honestly I never see her age
so I just feel like we're the same age
until she get hurt or anything like
literally we do everything the same and
it's all normal so I don't see her age
until she's hurt or something yeah
I don't want him to be different if he
were the exact same person and I could
have more time with him then yes but I
don't want him to change time it's like
when he's hitting a stride at 40 I'll be
close to 80 and I'll be decrepit I'm
thinking if you know looking at
80-year-olds in my in my family and I
don't want that for you I don't want you
to see me that way I don't want to see
myself that way but I definitely don't
want to see you so young and vital and
still this amazing man with whom I'm in
love to see me diminished and that's
just it's my fear it's not I don't get
that at all from you it's all internal
it's all me as much as it sounds like a
cliche you know I think in age Gap
relationship like living in the moment
living each day yeah we might not be
able to plan 40 years from now cuz what
will I be in 40 years like 70 dust I
wish right just oh no that's horrible
hit him horrible just can we just switch
can we just switch here so but you know
what I mean like we really like we
really like doing stuff like this and
traveling and just all the fun stuff
that we get to do it's like we're doing
it's like oh let let's plan that 10
years from now we might not have it I
mean he could get hit by a bus doesn't
mean like that I'm going to go first I
think about having a full life with you
all the time and a lot of people have
said about kids and I really want to I
want you to be my husband and we want I
want to Father with you I see how you
treat your nephews and nieces and it's
so special and the fact that we will
miss out on that just it breaks my heart
yeah that's really bad for us because I
can't have no more babies MH and he
doesn't have any and of course I want to
give him that so like I can't that we
talked about that before we even got
married like I can't be selfish because
we're we talked about it and I can't
have no babies but we're we've been
looking and trying with SAR gets for
what a year and a half almost two years
almost two years now so we are working
on it and it doesn't matter how old I am
because I have seven kids and I could
take care of kids no matter what I take
care of my grandbabies he's a grandpa of
17 um grandchildren 18 now cuz we just
found out one and they all call me and
stuff and Pops I see how she interact
with them and they all love it they love
to come
she got what say age doesn't
mean we can but once we had a child you
know no telling House's life is going to
bring us and take us cuz you can't I
don't think of that you don't want to
think ahead too far cuz you can't think
about tomorrow cuz you don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow so we just live
in the moment literally I'm Cheryl
McCain and I'm 63 years old I'm Kar
McCain and I am 26 years old and we have
a 37 year age cout if I call my partner
cheating I would give them a second
chance make your split decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around okay
okay uh Coran you seem very surprised I
was she said no and I said yes and it's
like damn I put myself out there okay
yeah I wouldn't take him back because
all the other guys relationships that I
was in they cheated on
me and I would not think that he would
anyways I'm I mean I know he wouldn't I
I said from day one before we even said
okay we're going to be in a relationship
it's going to be monogamous okay not to
say that if the two of us play with
somebody but it's it's never it's never
separate for me but John you disagree
yeah I mean we've been together 5 and a
half years and I know who you are I know
how you feel about me and if you were to
cheat or stray I know that I'm still the
person you want to come home with I've
only ever been in monogamous
relationships and I'm good at it I like
I like monogamy and then I met Trey and
he has he pushed for monogamy and I was
I stood back from it because I'm like I
don't think you're I don't think you're
ready for it you've not experienced
enough of life and gay life and I
appreciate the fact that you want to we
talk about about everything and in the
beginning it was like if you he's 22 and
he's got he's incredibly viral has an
incredible sex drive and I am not
22 and you know three or four times a
day I can't do it I've got I've got to
do you guys can speak on this for gay
couples it's a lot extra more work to
get ready for sex than it is for
straight couples whether it's not eating
for a whole day um or it's spending an
hour in the shower there's more that we
have
101 I think a lot of straight couples
don't know anything about this after we
have sex we talk about things and one of
those things that come up is that is
there something like I'm not giving him
that he needs and if he did sexual Chang
whatever like I don't care if you want
to go have sex with someone else if you
need that go do it I don't care that's
one of the things that bothers me a
little bit because I want him to care
sometimes not all the time it's okay
well let's see let's put that to the
test let's see what happens he hasn't
done it yet and Ne have I so Alejandra
you say yes yes but Talia you're no how
do you feel that Alejandra's on yes that
he would I knew he'd be there you knew
he'd be yeah he's very chill like he
doesn't kind of like what you were
saying like I kind of want them to care
a little bit like he doesn't care and
we've had before we got married there
were some times where he was open to me
exploring some things so if and I I
found her that she cheated on me uh
first of all it's going to hurt mhm and
after that probably we should we should
talk about it because probably we are uh
failing in in in in in some point I'm
Talia I'm 27 I'm Alejandro I'm 44 years
old and we are 16 years apart our age
Gap affects our political discourse make
your split decisions in three two
1 okay go ahead and turn
around oh W I was like no everybody's on
no okay
Trump clearly obviously we don't discuss
politics no we don't people have
different views on different parts of
life so I feel like even with my friends
I don't discuss politics with them
because whatever you like I may not like
and I'm not going to judge you for
whatever you like so I just we don't
it's not I'm the exact opposite yeah
same [__] you if you don't agree I think
yeah I'd rather see you burn I live
through AIDS I live through I buried
everybody I ever knew and we all came
together from Co which is great
but we still can't get a goddamn cure
for HIV AIDS so right we can't get real
gun legislation going for just like
normal stuff keep it out of the hands of
crazy people after Sandy Hook if nothing
was done nothing's ever going to right
that's right there just horrible like I
I I don't I don't I can't it it gets me
so riled up anything with but agewise it
is it's like we've we've seen a lot
we've lived through through the Gulf War
we've lived through AIDS we've buried
all of our friends that's interesting
for me because because I feel like you
have much stronger polarizing political
views and while I agree with your views
I don't feel as strong about them and so
you're just more politically driven and
I'm seeing Jeff as well you're you're
also driven and I'm just wondering if us
younger guys and and gals are are not as
political for because of your lived
experience has your partner ever said
something that triggered you you know
like oh maybe you shouldn't say that
chery's from a different time so it was
a lot of things that she had to readjust
to and learn what to say and what not to
say because of the age Gap that's
something that has stepped in I had to
teach her the new lingos of our stuff
cuz but she never said anything like to
you that was like well her kids have but
she has never she stood up for me one
time and I'm telling you I tried to
ignore the last one her son called her
on the phone and was like something
something something something about on
the couch all I did was turn my music up
I heard my wife immediately no you don't
say that to him this that whatever I was
so happy I was going to ignore his ass I
was like I'm act like I didn't hear it
but soon as she did that I was like that
just let me know like hey you really do
love cuz you cing out one of your sons
that she need it but she don't need them
so are you liking this episode do you
want to be in one see what we're casting
for at jubile media.com casting or check
the link in the description now let's
get back into it my partner has a vice
or bad habit that really worries me make
your split decision in three 2
[Music]
one okay go ahead and turn around
okay Karan that was a big reaction tell
me what's going on um she doesn't really
care for her mental health so she goes
in her own comment section and that
really bothers me cuz I don't read them
I know it's called Selfish posting but
you can't hurt me if I don't read it but
she like it's it's different for women
cuz you know y'all like affirmation and
y'all like to feel like hey I'm doing
good I'm doing beautiful you know all
that but we get a lot of hate in our
comment section and she goes there and I
feel like that's something that's
damaging her more than helping her and
that really bothers me cuz your mental
health I have to deal with it too so I
feel like you should do things to make
yourself feel better and not focus on
the negative I
know he
gets mad very very fast has a very short
temper and sometimes he lots of times he
takes me wrong and he thinks maybe it's
the things that I say and how I say them
because I'm older I don't know that I'm
set in my ways he hasn't lived as long
and went through as much stuff as I've
been through so and I was abused yeah in
my other relationships physically
mentally everything so and he's not so
but it kind of it bugs me because if you
were physically or mentally abused no
matter what if somebody yelled at you
like I kind of like want to shrink up
and like get like you know C my face and
you know it makes me feel less and so
what are you what are you both doing
about this right now we work on every
day this is something like marriage
isn't easy so you know you have to work
on it every day you have to get better
at it like I said we just it got better
from the beginning cuz the beginning we
she would well when we relationship
phase she would leave she would just
leave the house and go to her house now
we live together is a different thing
like we just eventually we either not
talk to each other for like 15 minutes
just be quiet and cuz you cannot a angry
person cannot hear what another angry
person is saying especially when you got
different views and vales of the
situation how it occurs so we just
learned to cool down then talk about
what offended you in this way and why
did it offend you that way Trey what is
the vice or bad habit
careful
relax um no this is going to sound super
sappy but Jeff is the most masculine
handsome sexy man I've ever had sex with
been with want to marry um and he has
the worst habit of demeaning himself
every single day oh yeah and to me it's
like I don't want him to feel as though
he's not good enough I just wish he
would stop looking at himself and being
like Oh I have this problem or that
problem because I think he's the sexiest
man ever I love him and I worry that
it's going to become a worse thing as he
gets older and like he said before like
when I'm 40 and when he's 80 or whatever
what will he think of himself cuz I
still want to be with him when I'm 40
and he's 80 I don't care I just wish he
would look at himself the way I look at
him every day in the mirror I sometimes
feel like an out Ider around my
partner's
friends make your split decision in 3 2
1 I'm
like me I don't I don't go ahead and
turn
[Music]
around wow okay so John you feel like an
outsider around he makes a lot of
references to his childhood you know
favorite you know singers songwriters
movies things like that he practically
knows the entire Greece soundtrack by
heart which is something that I don't
and so when you're you know chatting
with your friends and throwing out all
these references it's just completely
over my head and I feel like I'm not
part of that conversation and I know
that you do try and work me in at some
point sometimes it's just feels like I'm
alone and hi over here you know Olia
Newton John is a goddess and you need to
get goddess how many days did you cry
when she died oh my God I'm so yeah I
can't even I have an autograph picture
over my desk to Brian and it's the
grease cover from the you have no idea
no she was everybody's she was
everybody's girlfriend talking about she
saved us Brian did you know that he felt
this way yeah sometimes but he's the
worst in pop culture anyway so it
doesn't matter so if I talking about a
movie that's happening now it's like vom
vom vom like so you know but yes but
sometimes I get on that role because
that's kind of the one thing we can't
talk about and'll be like all excited
when I'm with people my age I try and
make sure that you're involved in in the
conversation more so than when we're
with your friends talking about your
usually that's when I go to the kitchen
and cook or drinks for
every so you don't feel like you feel
like he could try harder in like
including you in the conversation I
guess I guess so but also I know that
you have your own things and space and
that I need to give that to you and I
can't possibly learn 60 years of pop
culture like that so H Trey his best
friend is an older white guy and we with
him and whenever I go to any restaurant
you know it's one black guy with two
older white guys so already weird but I
mean I'm thinking specifically about
tonight we're going to a Halloween party
that is just his and his best friends
all their friends so it's just going to
be a black dot on a old white canvas and
you know I don't mind it but of course
like the question was you know do you
feel out of place or do you feel like
the outlier I'm kind of am I'm the 22
black kid in a room full of like 50
decrepit old white people yeah talking
about pets like oh my God how fun yeah
we met um at ocidental
College I he was an undergraduate I was
not and it was primarily a hookup and we
did that for a couple of weeks until we
decided we want to make this a real
thing my family approves of my partner
make your split decisions in three two
one all right go ahead and turn
around okay we got a lot of yes but you
know my family no it's just funny you
the only one over there well my family
doesn't approve of him and I don't care
if they do or not like I'm with him like
it doesn't make a difference I don't I
have seven children one child is there
for both this only one is approves mm of
the relationship yes because of they
call him the N word other one kids too
your your other kids call him the for no
reason I'm happy I've showed them this
they don't care they don't care about my
happiness apparently I don't talk to
seven of six of six of my children
because of your
relation and it hurts me but I love him
I love them too but I love them from
from a
distance I'm not going to give up
somebody that I've searched for all my
life that I found peace and everything
else and happiness it makes me want to
cry but my kids go I done did everything
for them cannot do no more why can they
not approve it hurts me daily how does
that impact you makes me emotional like
really like I ain't never felt love like
that before like from the time I met her
she literally quit her job because they
were racist and they said they didn't
want a n word dancing in the store and
she quit her job just met her ain't been
on her like nothing like a week or so
that was just pretty awesome the fact to
her own kids they have caught me in word
and stuff it hurts cuz it's like wow
like I do love her but she been abused
she been married twice before me the
marriages were horrible they beat her sa
her took whenever they wanted me I'm so
passionate it's when you want to if
you're not in the moood I'm not in the
moood it's just it's just stuff like
that and it's just like yo for her to
tell her own kids it's me I'm choosing
my happiness over y'all cuz they all are
grown and it's it's just the color and
age age really don't have a effect cuz
yeah they're older than me all themar
but not by are old with an old I've been
with the younger guy before him he was
27 years younger this was while back but
they approved him they did he was white
and it's not about the age that they're
upset about it's
race I just yeah my family accepts
Cheryl though wholeheartedly she comes
to the cookout barbecues yes they treat
her like normal they do we dance
together all barbecue
right but yeah that does make me feel
somewh I know you want your kids to be
there as a parent but we just can't get
them on the same track as us it hurts me
that I had to turn my back on him but I
have my husband now my life has
been hell raising them a single mom and
now my life is happy so do you think
that I want to jeopardize my
happiness to be friends or to be have my
children back in my life no so you don't
talk to them you say you don't talk to
them you don't see them ever nothing
like that just one just only one and the
way they hurt her the most cuz Cheryl's
all for family they didn't just stop
talking to her that would remove her
grandkids from her it kills me that I
can't see my
grandkids and I really don't want to
talk about it but
yes oh
sweetie that's what okay see that it's
like oh oh
[Laughter]
sorry can we get some more tissues I
take it
all CH was working at a gas station and
um I came in one day and she was crying
and I was like why are you crying lady
she was like download Tik Tok and they
were so rude so I was like hey forget
them people keep doing your thing you
did amazing and our friendship got
closer and grew and grew and then we end
up getting a relationship and married
and happy I often feel like no one
understands our
relationship make your split decisions
in three 2
1 okay go ahead and turn
around like I do feel yes then I was
like I don't know cuz I was like we do
get judged a lot for the age gu
especially a lot of older women they
judge Cheryl cuz they like oh she's
happy she's getting that you know young
whatever but yeah they said I was dead
they put a whole thing and said I died
on there and that was yeah yeah they
they they claimed I'm dead yeah on the
internet I had to come on there and say
no I'm still alive like because they
were angry about the age Gap yes that
hurts me to hear that as someone else
who is a content creator and puts out
videos on YouTube people didn't
understand us and I think putting our
lives out there people understand us
more when I first came out to my mom I
said hey Mom I'm gay and I'm dating
someone older than you wasn't me that
was it was with my it was it was my ex
and my mom called him a pedophile my mom
didn't at all understand everything that
I owned was thrown onto the front lawn
of my ex's yard and it took two years
for my mom to really come around and
understand things and now I think being
open and honest and just comfortable in
my own skin it it has allowed others to
see I love this man and he loves me and
and when people see that they they see
the passion for each other I think their
you know their worries kind of Melt Away
we'll get the comments that it's like
you know gold digger like for him or
just like pedophile or whatever and but
for the majority it's like it's the
like-minded people that give us the
positive but in person you'll you're
never going to get that because I always
feel people on the internet are a lot
Bolder people think that we're Father
and Son you got you look just like your
father then I'll just lip lock him right
in front of
them say yeah go for a kiss right there
yeah are there any other stereotypes
that you come across Grandma and Grandpa
I mean Grandma and Grandson yeah Grandma
grandson yeah Daddy Issues daddy daddy
issues yes mommy issues they say him I
got her from retirement
home using me they they say my money
which I don't have that's the weird with
age gu relationships they always seem it
has to be money I guess cuz the way
Hollywood with the you know Playboy
Bunny house and all that stuff have to
fall into it but you don't if you
genuinely love someone money has no
factors in the relationship I feel like
we get more of like it was just a green
card marriage that's the Assumption they
see that that it was just for the green
card and all of that without knowing the
threeyear immigration process that we
went through I lived in Ecuador with him
during that time like I wouldn't do that
just to give him a green card you know I
think we get more maybe more stairs or
like people looking at us um for that
reason than a when people knows the the
difference uh some of them call me a
baby Thief a baby Thief
baby
robber in Spanish I thought it in
Spanish so I was looking
for
robber cradle robber robber so so we met
back in 2018 when I was studying abroad
in Ecuador I was in a relationship at
the time so I wasn't pursuing anything
but kind of hung out as friends he
showed me around Ecuador and I knew it
was time to get out of that previous
relationship and we started dating
there's something only my partner
understands about me
make your split decisions in three two
1 all right go ahead and turn
around Karan you want to start us off so
once we started making Tik toks me and
Cheryl we um had a moment where we went
to the park this was like our first date
and so when we went there me and Cheryl
went to the park we talked about
basically a lot of things happened in
our past we both got sexually assaulted
we've been in domestic violence
relationships
we we both of you both of us
yes and so that's where we really
connected we cried we we talked about
the pain it costed whatever and that's
where we connected that was our anchor
our our friendship that moved into a
relationship and that same day I
confessed and told her I had feelings
for her and she was like friends don't
always um say friends you know when they
cross that line but that's where we
really anchored our love it off the
abuse we both went through yeah that's
how we actually bonded it brought us so
much closer together because we felt
each other's pain like it's not too
often that you feel somebody else's pain
by being with them but we did and I
helped him which I'm hoping get rid of
some of the pain like I did to like the
things that I did to overcome it like
the molestation the abuse and stuff like
I explained to him how to try to get let
some of it Go by writing a letter and
and burning some times it helps because
we've been through so
much um how would you say it sensitive
things that a lot of people have not
gone through and and it really made us
Bond like big time I think when ours
started it was it was great and then he
decided to go to PA school and but it
wasn't around Providence it was going to
be in Pennsylvania so that meant a two
years away and it's it's tough when you
were we in the relationship a year maybe
more 4 PA school yeah and so for me it
was kind of devastating that I was going
to have to be alone but it it was a lot
and then when you look back you're like
oh it really wasn't that bad but like in
the moment you're like this really sucks
the distance actually maybe helped us in
a certain way because we became very
creative
we when we saw each other yes we saw
each other a lot
MH so the way Brian and I met was I was
moving up to Providence Rhode Island and
he had an apartment that he was renting
out I got out to the car after the walk
through and I told my mom oh my gosh he
is so hot if you weren't here right now
I would have gotten my knees and done
something so then like a year later this
guy comes up to me at the gym and he's
like hey I think we know each other like
you showed me your apartment and I was
like oh my gosh and one thing led to
another he's like hey you know you want
to work out together so then we just
started working out together at the gym
and it kind of developed into something
kind of cool much much more yeah I want
to start a family with my partner
someday make your split decisions in
three 2
1 okay go ahead and turn
around okay almost all of us say yes
that's a shocker but John you say no you
want to speak on that I want to start a
family with you I don't think it's fair
to our children to put them through the
loss of a father at such a young age
which is something that I went through
and I don't I guess that's my own lived
experience biasing this um that would
that's a lot to go through so I just as
much as I know that you'd be an awesome
father I just don't think it's fair to
the kids yeah and I I get that and it's
almost more cuz like I want to do it for
you type thing you know and I know it's
it's it's uh it would kind of be unfair
but like my mom's 98 not that a
20-year-old wants to have a 98y old dad
or something but you know I don't know I
I've constantly think about it because I
think we would be great parents we
totally would and I know we would make
it work but it's
I I understand not wanting to put your
kids through that loss like imagine like
going through college and you know you
have a definite family but at the flip
side wouldn't it be unfair to not give
your kids the best father you say like
he's already going to be amazing father
and I mean it's like having a pet you
worship those years that you had with it
rather than thinking about oh the
downsides of going without it yes at
least give your kids like the chance to
have 18 years with the best father that
you can provide
yes maybe we start with a
dog are you are you a hard no could you
be convinced I could totally be
convinced I think if if you're all in
I'm all in but I just again my bias my
Liv to experience is that it's a lot to
go through the loss of a loved one of a
parent like that and yeah because you
lost your dad young so yeah yeah um I
feel really grateful cuz being the
younger female in the relationship being
the one that would bear the children I
have never felt any pressure from him
and I think that's something that I was
worried about you know getting into
something like this if anything he's
like no not yet like we not ready I'm
I'm a little worried about uh my age
because I want to play soccer I went to
play baseball I went to play basketball
with my with my child or I'm turning all
every day so I'm I'm thinking in that so
and I think that's why in this
relationship and an age Gap relationship
you have to cherish every day and that's
also it makes it magical because you
know there is somewhat of an expiration
date on it and while I don't think it
would be fair to the children yeah it's
also unfair to us I think we would be
awesome dads you kidding me it's it's
it's something that I grapple with daily
and I'm glad to hear that you would do
it for me and with me and like I said
I've seen you with the nieces and
nephews and you are a kick ass human
and so does our time here together
change your
answer
awesome and how does it feel right now
that it's it's cool now it's like now
you know maybe we're those Gates have
opened a little more and you know I can
work my way in doesn't have to be like
an
infant there PL older kids ad
absolutely Trey Jeff how does it impact
you both knowing that your future is you
know cut short by the age Gap that's
something we have talked about we have
focused on I mean just the other day we
were I asked them can you write down
baby names for
me because it's the fact that which made
me want to SB actually I know I want to
have a family regardless and I want to
have it with him but I don't want his
memory to be lost on my children
cuz he's been the most impactful person
in my whole life and just then he was
like I promise you we're going to have
kids together and so everything like you
ask me about if time is fleeting you
know how do I grapple it I don't grapple
with it anymore because and it might be
in 2 years 3 years four years we're
going to have a little baby boy that can
say papa Trey and papa Jeff I want to
thank you all so much for sharing your
sights with the world cuz I really think
you're going to make a huge difference
for all of our viewers and everyone out
there sadly we've reached the end of
this episode join us next time as best
friends share their deepest secrets and
stories I love you I love you the best
thing in the world you're the only thing
that
matters love you love you too Brian I
love you I love you more I love you
most